DRAW FROM HIS EXPERIENCE.
STEVE: HE WHO KNOWS WHAT THE
FUTURE WILL HOLD BUT WE WILL
GET INTO THAT LATER.
ALL RIGHT.
FIRST, WE HAVE SOMETHING MUCH
MORE EXCITING TO PRESENT TO
YOU.
SOMETHING THAT RELATES TO THE
BIG NEWS THAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEK.
THE KINGS AND SWINGS OF
CATASTROPHE.
TO THE LEFT THESE DAYS
EVERYTHING IS A DISASTER.
>> ALL OF THE ALARMS HAVE
SOUNDED.
IT WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A
CATASTROPHE.
>> THERE ARE ALMOST NO SOULS
IN WASHINGTON WHO BELIEVE THIS
IS ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
COMPLETE AND UTTER
CATASTROPHE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING THE
APOCALYPSE.
STEVE: THE APOCALYPSE
THIS WEEK OF COURSE IT WAS THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> THE CORONAVIRUS IS
SPREADING AND THE NUMBERS ARE
STUNNING AT THIS POINT.
>> LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
>> COULD BE TRULY
CATASTROPHIC.
>> IF IT CAN IMPACT THE FIFTH
OF THE POPULATION IT WILL BE A
CATASTROPHE, YES.
STEVE: BUT THIS IS WHAT THEY
ALWAYS DO.
A FEW MONTHS AGO IT WAS THE
LOOMING ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE.
>> I THINK THAT’S WHERE THE
TALK OF A TRUMP RECESSION IS
REALLY STARTING TO BUILD UP.
A LOT OF GLOBAL LEADERS ARE
BLAMING TRUMP FOR THE GLOBAL
RECESSION THAT WE ARE SEEING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PUSHING
US INTO A RECESSION.
WE ARE FEELING IT IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS AND IT WILL BE
THE TRUMP RECESSION.
STEVE: THEY LIKEN IT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> NUMBER ONE THE BIGGEST
ISSUE FACING THE WORLD’S
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE IT CAN
KILL US ALL.
IT WILL AFFECT EVERYTHING WE
DO IN OUR NATION.
>> THE WORLD WILL END IN 12
YEARS IF WE DON’T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
STEVE: OVER THE SOLEIMANI
STRIKE WHEN THEY SAID IT WAS
THE START OF WORLD WAR III.
>> WE ARE SUDDENLY ADD AN
EXTREMELY PERILOUS MOMENT.
ONE RECKLESS ACT BY THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
>> THE CHANCES OF WAR ARE MORE
SERIOUS NOW THAN THEY HAVE
BEEN IN THE LAST 40 YEARS.
>> HERE WE ARE TODAY CLOSER TO
WAR WITH IRAN THAN WE’VE EVER
BEEN.
STEVE: IF IT’S NOT HEALTH,
ECONOMIC, SECURITY
CATASTROPHE, IT’S A
CATASTROPHE OF DEMOCRACY.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET HIM
JUST TORCH THIS DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING TO SAVE
OUR COUNTRY THAT MUST BE
STOPPED.
>> HIS ASSAULT ON THE RULE OF
LAW.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
DOESN’T BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF
LAW OR FREEDOM OF PRESS.
STEVE: BUT IT’S ALL JUST AN
ILLUSION.
THE RECESSION THEY TALKED
ABOUT NEVER CAME.
IN FACT THE ECONOMY GOT EVEN
STRONGER WITH THE LAST JOBS
REPORT EXCEEDING EXPECTATIONS,
EARNINGS CONTINUING TO GROW
AND WE CAN SEE THE CONFIDENCE
REMAINING HIGH.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE, OUR
EMISSIONS ARE ACTUALLY GOING
DOWN, NOT UP.
IN FACT, LAST YEAR AMERICA HAD
THE BIGGEST REDUCTION OF ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
DEATHS FROM NATURAL DISASTERS
ARE FIVE TIMES LOWER THAN
1980, NOT TO MENTION THE FACT
THAT THE EARTH IS ACTUALLY
BECOMING GREENER AS WE SPEAK.
THE ARM AGAIN AND THEY
PREDICTED AFTER HE TOOK OUT
ONE OF THE WORLD’S MOST
DANGEROUS TERRORIST, WERE
STILL WAITING FOR THE COLLAPSE
OF THE RULE OF LAW AT HOME,
TELL THAT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO IS CONSTANTLY BEING
THWARTED AND FRUSTRATED BY THE
CONGRESS AND COURTS FROM
EVERYTHING FROM EXECUTIVE
POWER AND POLICIES.
I THINK YOU’LL FIND THAT
CHECKS AND BALANCES ARE
WORKING REALLY WELL.
AS FOR TRUMP CURTAILING THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS, MY GOD,
CAN ANYONE THINK THE PRESIDENT
WHO HAS FACED A MORE HOSTILE
MEDIA THAN THIS ONE?
AFTER THEIR ENDLESS
PRODUCTIONS OF EMINENT
DISASTER ON EVERY SUBJECT,
FORGIVE US IF WE DON’T TAKE
THE DEMOCRATS SERIOUSLY WITH
THEIR LATEST CATASTROPHIZE
THING ON CORONAVIRUS.
OF COURSE IT SERIOUS AND WE
SHOULD TAKE SENSIBLE
PRECAUTIONS PRECAUTIONS.
WHILE THEY WERE BUSY
IMPEACHING HIM, THAT’S EXACTLY
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
DOING, CLOSING THE BORDER TO
HIGH RISK VISITORS AND GETTING
GOING ON A VACCINE.
HE DISCUSSED TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS YESTERDAY AND
THAT’S GREAT BUT HE SHOULD GO
EVEN FURTHER.
BEFORE ANYONE SCREAMS THAT’S
RACIST AND EXTREME, CHECK OUT
THIS COLUMN FROM THE NEW YORK
TIMES EPIDEMIC EXPERT DONALD
MCNEIL.
HE WAS LITERALLY THE PERSON
THAT RACHEL MADDOW PUT ON HER
SHOW AS HER VOICE OF REASON.
HE BACKED TOUGH TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS AND HARSH
MEASURES HORRIFY LIBERTARIANS
BUT THEY OFTEN SAVE LIVES
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY ARE
IMPOSED IN THE EARLY DAYS.
THREE OTHER PRACTICAL STEPS,
MAKE SURE AMERICANS DON’T GET
CHARGED FOR CORONAVIRUS
TESTING.
MAKE SURE PEOPLE GET PAID SICK
LEAVE SO THERE’S NO ECONOMIC
INCENTIVE TO COME TO WORK AND
SPREAD GERMS AND JUST STOP THE
TRUMP HATERS, HAVE A DAILY
PRESS BRIEFING FROM THE
MEDICAL EXPERT.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, LISTEN TO
DOCTOR.
[INAUDIBLE]
DON’T MUZZLE DOCTOR FAUCI.
HE’S NOT BEING MUZZLED AS HE
HIMSELF SAID BUT A BIG POINT
OF THIS IS LET’S LISTEN TO
DOCTOR FAUCI.
WHAT DID HE SAY YESTERDAY?
THE HIGHEST CORONA VIRUS RISK
ARE THOSE WITH HEART DISEASE,
LUNG DISEASE, DIABETES AND
OBESITY.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS IS PREVENTABLE.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO PREVENT
THEM WE ACTIVELY ENCOURAGE
THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE ON HEART DISEASE
AND OBESITY, THE TOTALLY
CORRUPT NUMBERS ON BOTH
PARTIES, STATE LEGISLATORS IN
BOTH PARTIES DOING THE BIDDING
OF BIG FOOD AND BIG
AGRICULTURE BY SUBSIDIZING
FOOD THAT KILLS US AND
PENALIZING FOOD THAT IS GOOD
FOR US, BUT AS USUAL, THE
IDIOT MEDIA AND THE IDIOT
POLITICIANS CHASE SUPERFICIAL
NONSENSE INSTEAD OF THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE.
SO, LET’S GET THINGS IN
PROPORTION.
OVER 10 MILLION AMERICANS GOT
THE FLU OVER THE PAST YEAR.
HOW MANY HAVE CAUGHT THIS
VARIANCE OF THE FLU IN AMERICA
QUESTION MIKE SO FAR FOR.
BUT THE FACTS AND THE SCIENCE
DON’T MATTER TO THE KINGS AND
QUEEN OF CATASTROPHE.
THEY NEED CATASTROPHE FOR
THEIR OBSESSION OF GROWING THE
GOVERNMENT AND HATING TRUMP.
>> ANEMIC IN TERMS OF
AGGRESSION AGGRESSION, THEN
THERE WAS EBOLA THAT WAS
5 MILLION IN THERE TRYING TO
TAKE THAT MONEY.
[INAUDIBLE]
WHAT HE’S DOING IS LATE, TOO
LATE.
>> FORWARDS, DESCRIBE THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO
THE CORONAVIRUS, TOWERING AND
DANGEROUS INCOMPETENCE.
>> HE LOVES THOSE FORWARDS.
HE SAID IT FIVE TIMES IN 24
HOURS.
MEANWHILE THE MEDIA KEEP
COMPARING CORONAVIRUS TO
EBOLA.
>> IF SOMEONE WAS IN CHARGE OF
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE FOR THE
GOVERNMENT THE WAY PRESIDENT
PUT SOMEONE IN CHARGE FOR
EBOLA.
>> WHEN I WAS IN CHARGE I DID
NO INTERVIEWS.
I WAS IN THERE 18 HOURS A
DAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
BUT FOR GOODNESS SAKE, THE
EBOLA COMPARISONS ARE
RIDICUUS.
ACCORDING TO CHINA CDC THE
CORONA VIRUS DEATH RATE IS
4.9%.
THE DEATH RATE FOR EBOLA WAS
90%.
90% WERE SPREAD THE DEMOCRATS
ARE PUSHING STUPID STUNTS
BASED ON POLITICAL PREJUDICE
AND DOGMA.
ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS TO TAKE
MONEY FROM BORDER SECURITY
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY OPENING OUR
BORDERS IS A BRILLIANT WAY TO
FIGHT THE DISEASE SPREADING
ACROSS COUNTRIES.
WHAT WE’VE SEEN THIS WEEK IS
THE MEDIA AND THE POLITICIANS
UNHEALTHY ADDICTION TO DRAMA
AND HYPE.
LISTEN TO ONE ACTUAL HEALTH
OFFICIAL SET.
>> THE CORONAVIRUS IS LIKE A
COMMON COLD.
SOMETHING MANY OF YOU MAY ALSO
BE FAMILIAR WITH.
THE CAUSE OF THE ORIGINAL
OUTBREAK IN CHINA IS A MEMBER
OF THIS FAMILY.
MOST PEOPLE, MORE THAN 85%
WILL HAVE MILD OR NO
SYMPTOMS.
STEVE: MOST PEOPLE WILL HAVE
MILD OR NO SYMPTOMS.
ALWAYS A LETDOWN FOR THE KINGS
AND QUEENS OF CATASTROPHE.
THE ENVIRONMENT IS GETTING
BETTER.
THE ECONOMY IS GETTING
STRONGER.